robocalls are not just annoying more
than 40% of them are believed to be
scams Microsoft discovered last year
that more than 60% of people across 16
countries including the US were targeted
in tech support scams in some cases a
fraudster called promising to fix their
computer CTM consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Werner has been
looking into how some people are
fighting back against the people running
those schemes Anna well Michele have you
ever wished you could get back at the
scammers who are plaguing you with robo
calls on your phone well this morning
we're taking you behind the scenes with
some of the people tracking where those
scams originate now one group works for
a company whose name you'll know
immediately it runs its own full-blown
digital crime bureau the other just one
man you're looking at the webcam of a
scammer named Ewa the voice on this
YouTube video is a man who calls himself
Jim groaning he won't disclose his real
name and didn't want us to show his face
for his own safety I tried my best to
keep safe the people he's after our
scammers in India making robo calls to
people they hope will fall for their
computer repair schemes hi we are
calling you from Microsoft refund
apartment here in this video Jim
connects with the con artist then plays
the victim listening as the scammers
tell him they need access to his
computer so they can give him a refund
and they will typically use the phrase
like we are a computer company going out
of business you've paid us in the past
and we're going to refund your money
Jim lets them into his computer but what
they don't realize is he's about to turn
the tables by now accessing their
computer and spying on their operations
once in he watches them the officers are
very small and prompt listens to them
and worms his way into their system
courtesy of this particular scammer
we're going to get a little tear of
exactly what the office looks like his
unorthodox strategy for going after
scammers has proved popular on YouTube
where this video has garnered more than
two million views
what is your goal in helping to expose
these people one is really want to get
back at these guys but the other ones
just Ria's awareness of scams in general
and particularly these type of scams but
there's somebody else tracking the
scammers someone equally determined but
a lot more powerful our frontline
customer support services folks we're
getting phone calls from around the
globe
welcome to the Microsoft cybercrime
Center this is our lab where Courtney
Gregoire works with an international
team of over 60 people to disrupt cyber
crimes including tech repair scams
you know this cybercrime is really
happening at scale these networks behind
these cyber criminals are trying to get
millions of victims the company's scam
reporting web page receives more than
12,000 complaints from customers every
month 12 to 13 thousand complaints a
month a month and so at this point we've
got almost over 500,000 data points for
us to think about how can we figure out
the criminal networks behind this fraud
dele was our first operation Microsoft -
and after call centers running scams in
India but on a much larger scale working
with and providing intelligence to law
enforcement overseas one of the results
a bust last November in two cities in
India that took down 16 call centers and
resulted in the arrests of 68 people
it's expensive so why is Microsoft
willing to spend the money for a whole
Bureau of people just to go after cyber
criminals couldn't you just say to
customers look we sell a product fraud
is not our problem why is it worth it
for Microsoft to even do it we think
that this type of cyber fraud is really
undermining fundamentally customer trust
in technology not just Microsoft the
only way they're gonna use it as if they
trust it meanwhile Jim found a way to
make it a lot harder for this fraud
operation to market their scam he says
he quietly replaced the robo call they
were sending out with one of his own
same computerized voice different
message this is just a scam so that they
can access your computer and will try to
get money from your bank account if you
ever get a message like this it is
always
scam by the way the man who calls
himself Jim does say that breaking into
the scammers computers is probably
illegal but he doesn't think that
they're going to want to go to the
authorities to complain about it before
he posted his YouTube video he turned
over his evidence to the local Indian
cyber police force but he never heard
back we also reached out to them but we
got no response revenge is sweet I get
these all the time yeah one how do you
fight it - where's the conscience well
that's you have to ask the guys in India
you know they have a lot of what they
say they have a lot of legitimate call
centers in India that's where a lot of
that business is set up and then you
have this sort of percentage that is you
know doing it for scams and I think for
a lot of people there it's it's a job
yeah you know you get hired to do either
the good stuff or the or the bad stuff
has Jim's work been able to lead to any
cases he's trying he tries to you know
he wants he actually says that he would
prefer that the police go after these
people and then he wouldn't post his
video right but when they don't then he
posts this video and here's a lot of
people sort of living psychically
through Jimmy yes there were more Jim's
I need an army of Jim's thank you very
much